I think the average millionaire becomes
rich by starting their own small
business a lot of people you know are
sort of born into it some of them work
really hard in something steel I would
say it's family money it's old money I
think it's a combination of working hard
being responsible with their money
smarts being organized and there's no
way to do it without hard work some of
the major causes of poverty the cycle of
poverty doesn't help which really is
guess the root cause lack of education
yeah poverty is just a vicious cycle
there's not a lot of money being put out
on the bottom level I think poor money
management I say big problem was just
getting born into it and people thinking
if there's no way out of it
I definitely think it's possible to get
out of poverty one way to do that is
like I said earlier to network try make
sure you're getting in touch with the
right people it just depends on your
depends on a lot of factors a lot to be
there
hard work could be there but not only
hard work to get you to be rich it takes
them consciously making that decision
opens receiving help I mean all it
really takes is willpower because we all
have the same opportunity
I've been a bunch of people on Twitter
over the last four or five months asking
me to comment on a string of articles it
seems to be building on each other and
there's just some absolutely ridiculous
moronic things being printed I think it
started probably with this Bloomberg
Businessweek article that Charles Kenny
did how did the world's rich get that
way and basically this was back in April
and he goes through and I'm not gonna
read you the whole article because it'll
make you puke it's just Charles you're a
[ __ ]
seriously unbelievable the premise of
the article is is that when you compare
the rich to the poor the biggest factor
contributing to their wealth isn't the
decisions they've made it's blind luck
we are a long way from equality of
opportunity the rich are rewarded for
the same effort far more than the poor
the wealth of children can be explained
by the wealth of their parents half of
all jobs in the US are found through
friends and family wealth results from
nepotism these are the things he's
saying I mean these things are just
ridiculous at any level beyond the local
differences in income due to inequality
of opportunity dwarfed those from
inequality due to effort or Talent the
choices people make are certainly
important when it comes to how
successful they are compared to their
school friends or colleagues but luck
not hardwork is overwhelmingly why the
rich are rich while the poor are poor
USA Today did a Robert Frank did an
article called is the key to getting
rich risk or luck if we assume that
wealth comes from working hard taking
great personal risk and coming up with
great ideas then the wealthy didn't it
don't necessarily know Society for their
success but if the rich are simply lucky
or if they get wealthy on the back of
America's publicly funded infrastructure
they owe more of a debt in the form of
taxes or philanthropy see that's the
core of this it's socialism it's the
operation of Wall Street morons the
concept of you know wealth is in equal
is unequal so we have to figure out that
it's random and it's blind luck as
Charles Kinney says New York Times
article in April robert frank says
although people are often quick to
ascribe their own success
it's a skill and hard work even those
qualities entail heavy elements of luck
a person salary depends far more on
where she is born than on her talent and
effort hmm
Princeton commencement speech author
Michael Lewis says success often comes
from luck yet the successful often
rationalize their successes stemming
from talent or worker intelligence see
these are just absolutely ridiculous
because all the evidence as opposed to
you liberal Socialists mentality all the
evidence supports otherwise see the
premise of this is the guy who works at
Walmart just wasn't as lucky as Sam
Walton the guy who works at Dell just
wasn't as lucky as Michael Dell the gal
who works for Microsoft just wasn't as
lucky as old Bill Gates he was just
lucky the guy who drives the golf cart
he's not as lucky as Tiger Woods the guy
who's putting up the lighting and
stringing it up on an hourly rate he's
not as lucky as Brad Paisley yeah who
works at chick-fil-a he's not as lucky
as true a Cathy it was just blind luck
do you hear how ridiculous this is
this is absolutely moronic the problem
is these guys keep beating this drum and
beating this drum beating this drum and
it does two things one is is it rolls
socialism in with a red carpet this idea
that wealth has to be redistributed
because it was just random line luck I
mean you don't have any right to claim
your success was from hard work or
talent or both and so you owe society
that's problem number one problem number
two is if it's blind luck
why work why go get a degree why study
why Reid why get better why why practice
your craft doesn't matter it's luck you
see how demotivating that is Churchill
said socialism is government of the duds
by the duds and for the duds that's what
we're talking about here it's grading
the whole frickin culture on a curve
because they're too freakin lazy to work
they won't get up leave the cave kill
something and drag it home here's the
interesting thing all of these things
say well it's you know where you were
born the family you're in you know I
said that you know the way you if you
didn't get that education let me help
you with this 80% of America's
millionaires according to Tom Stanley
who wrote the book million or next door
eight out of ten of America's
millionaires are first-generation rich
they started with nothing they became a
millionaire but now see they didn't they
that was just luck because they of
course they they didn't overspend and
they saved money and they invested money
and they they drove an older car and
they paid cash for things and they
invested in their 401 K and they worked
hard and they showed up every day and
they told the truth and they read books
and got better at their job and they
made more money every decade as they
went along because they had a career
track they were on and they were
thinking and they were growing their
business and they were coming up with
ideas and putting them into the
marketplace to serve people but they
were just lucky it was what Charles can
you say blind luck so I called him a
[ __ ]
because he's a [ __ ] that's why I call
him that that's ridiculous it's absurd
it's just it's above the pale it's it's
the idea that that a farmer who plants
seed and gets a crop after watering it
and doing all the the weeding and making
sure that the land is taken care of
versus the farmer who just stands back
and looks at the dirt is lucky when his
harvest comes in it was just luck it was
just luck had nothing to do with
superior intelligence spear
here math skills superior music skills I
mean Michael Jordan is just luck
he was luckier than I was I didn't get
to dunk a basketball like that I can't
do that with a basketball he's lucky he
has no more talent than I do
he didn't work harder at basketball than
I do he doesn't have physical
intelligence that I had don't have he
was just lucky the same things true in
business there's Michael Jordan's and
Tiger Woods all in the business world
and luck had nothing to do with it had
nothing to do with it and so I've quit
saying I'm lucky for instance I have two
fabulous young men that married my
daughters I have the two best
sons-in-law on the planet I really am
proud to call them my sons and I made
the mistake for a while I was going
around going man I hit the son-in-law
lottery and I finally won I can't say
that anymore cuz it was not an accident
for 20 years I taught my girls how to
pick a stud how to pick a man how to
pick a man that knows how to serve in
his household and knows how to work and
knows how to walk with the Lord I taught
them how to pick it wasn't an accident
it wasn't blind luck you're so lucky you
hear daughters married well yeah I
taught them oh and by the way they're
couple jerks drove up and I run them off
to I'll be here cleaning my gun when you
guys get home don't pull out in front of
my house pick up one of my girls don't
care unless you're delivering a pizza
that's how things work man it's not an
accident it's not luck you reap what you
sow we live in a cause-and-effect
universe and business and wealth are no
different you're saying all the poor
people are not as talented in some cases
that's true in some cases things have
happened to them and there's people
beating up on them I'm all about giving
them every advantage giving some I've
been broke twice in my life I started
with nothing
and I went completely broken had to
start over I'm so stupid I had to do it
twice so I'm like really lucky is this
ridiculous this is ridiculous
there's all kinds of evidence otherwise
folks not only just anecdotal as we paid
you have walking around since in the
culture if you were to actually leave
the media room at Bloomberg and go visit
real human beings you'd find these
things out but you know go get my friend
Jim Collins book he wrote the book good
to great he's got a new one out couple
months back called great by choice Jim
and I were sitting in a green room
together he was grinning he's a big
research fanatic he researches
everything to the nth degree he says
Dave I've discovered luck and it's not
luck it's a formula it's work and talent
apply to the marketplace and I'm gonna
show you in his new book right my choice
you gotta read it